alaba gomez lukas meine liebe zuschauer
wie wir reagieren heute zusammen auf
whatsapp welt des idm hier schreibt ein
mädel schatz wo bist du eher antworten
bin an der bushaltestelle und wartete
auf den bus daraufhin sie wieder beeil
dich und er antwortet dann einfach alles
klar ich warte einfach schneller
allerdings gerät weiter mit dem nächsten
whatsapp fällen und zwar schreibt hier
jemand junge wo bist du daraufhin
antwortet die andere person verstecke
mich hier in den büschen da sind so
typen mit taschenlampen die mich suchen
hilf mir junge das sind wir
m
alles klappt bisher waren die ersten
beiden nicht so lustig aber wir waren
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten umfeld
und verschreibt sich jemand gestern
abend wollten zwei frauen etwas langes
und hartes von mir
daraufhin antwortet die andere person
halt was hast du getan und daraufhin
schreibt er wiederum ich habe ihnen
meine hausaufgaben gegeben lang und hart
letztens meiner mutter deine mutter
witze erklärt und dann dann hat sie
gesagt deine mutter sammelt hässliche
kinder
das wasser komplett aber ich sehe auch
komplett egal wir haben erst auf 14 fans
reagiert derzeit wird sagen wir machen
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten wochen
gegen sein übergewicht hilft leichte
gymnastik daraufhin antwortet er halt
meinst du liegestützen und so und
daraufhin meinen sie dann wiederum nein
es genügt ein kopfschütteln wenn man die
etwas zu essen anbietet
der war
sagen wir mal komplett beschissen in der
tat selbst gespräche kann ich nur führen
wenn ich betrunken bin sowieso nüchtern
bin ich irgendwie immer zu schüchtern
einen hübschen mann anzusprechen die
heuer komplett hast du gerade zeit nein
ich prüfe wichtige unterlagen du liegst
paul auf dem bett rum eine matratze ist
eine wichtige unterlage
wer denkt sich so was aus aber
vielleicht bringt uns ja der nächste
wort fällt so richtig zum co -laden ich
glaube es war weniger aber wir schauen
wir uns mal an mit dem ich mit ihr
zusammen bin kann ich nicht mehr essen
trinken oder rauchen
liebst du mich so sehr nee ich kann es
mir nicht mehr leisten
papa habe eine 5 im biotest geschrieben
welches thema verhütung da sind wir wohl
beide schlecht drin
also ich glaube so langsam solltet ihr
wissen warum im titel nur whatsapp fans
stets und nicht irgendwie lustige motto
steht ich habe halt tausende videos
sehen den trends gesehen mit whatsapp
face et cetera und hatte auch kurz
reingeschaut und dachte das ist ja vorne
und hinten nicht witzig ich weiß nicht
findet ihr diese ganze whatsapp fällt so
lustig und cool hat euch jetzt den berg
runter vergleich ist meinem ohr dafür
einfach zu beschränkt aber ich habe
bisher noch keiner so richtig gelacht
aber er wir machen weiter mit nächsten
papa bin ich eigentlich hübsch keine
ahnung fragt doch deine freundin ich
habe keine eben
ziemlich gemeine vater hurra ich habe
eine eins in mathe wtf mama was denkst
du was wtf heißt war total fantastisch
papa darf ich dich was fragen wegen dem
sex mit meiner freundin ja mein sohn
könntest du das bitte
ja noch nicht schlimm da wärst du
manchmal gerne einen mann nein
eigentlich nicht und wie sieht es mit
dir aus max
er war ein starker konter schatz wie
lange brauchst du um den großen tisch
aufzubauen 15 minuten und wenn ich dir
helfen 2
ich glaube wir kommen so langsam eine
gewisse lustigere richtung wenn ich tot
bin spende ich mein gehirn der
wissenschaft gute idee die können
bestimmt noch einen türstopper im labor
gebrauchen also wir wir wir bessern uns
no shit zu beginn dachte ich wirklich
also juli hat mir die ganzen sachen
übrigens rausgesucht
also ich habe die whatsapp fällt so
nicht vorhergesehen zu begehen dass ich
mir auf jeden fall wirklich so hey was
ist das für eine bescheuerte scheiße
aber jetzt gerade sind wir auf einem
guten weg dass das ganze ein bisschen
lustiger wird also ich bin gespannt auf
den nächsten mein terminkalender ist
komplett voll kenne ich zu gut termine d
voll sein
und da sind wir mit dem lustigkeit
niveau auch schon wieder
oh mann war das ne party totaler
blackout ich bin mit dir nach hause
gelaufen oder ich war überhaupt nicht da
das ist eine normale unterhaltung einem
sonntagmorgen und wie läuft physik
lernen so ganz gut was kannst du nicht
physik face time lags smiley ruhig aber
gerade hier schon diesmal dies sehe die
darauf geantwortet wurden mich würd's
mal mega interessieren also halt
realtech was ist euer meist genutzter
smiley auf dem handy also meiner ist der
hier der ja okay das ist eigentlich nur
der standort smiley die pizza isst nur
auf ihr gefragt was ist falsch mit mir
schreiben wir bei euren meist genutzten
immobilie also der ganz oben bei euch
angezeigt wird unten in die kommentare
das würde mich echt gerade mal
interessieren was allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten rottweil und
zwar schreibt jemand seiner mutter mama
hat ein neues handy bluetooth und
daraufhin antwortet die mutter nein
vodafone das könnte tatsächlich auch
meine mutter sein schatz unser sohn hat
seinen ersten zahn verloren ja ich weiß
jetzt geht ja nicht mehr so schnell an
meine konsole der dad hat dem sohn
einfach ein zahn ausgeschlagen höchst
interessant meine frau hat sich gestern
bei einem unfall beide beine gebrochen
oh gott die armen an die backe
er war ehrlich gesagt auch wieder gar
nicht so schlecht gehen wir also direkt
erwartungsvoll in den nächsten 10 verein
und zwar schreibt ihr jemand ich habe
morgen einen arzttermin aber ich will
nicht hingehen daraufhin antwortet der
andere einfach sagt doch einfach du bist
krank
das ist dann wieder jetzt der tiefpunkt
erreicht haben kann ich auch ein stück
von deinem donath haben ja klar du
bekommst die mit wow deutschen comedy
preis geht an dich hier fragt jemand
seinen kollegen was ist deine
lieblingsfarbe daraufhin antwortet er
weiß nicht und daraufhin schreibt die
andere personen wiederum welche dann
oh oh mein gott okay der ist ja mal so
schlecht dass es da eine lieblingsfarbe
weiß nicht muss ich ihn wissen musste
ich ein bisschen nachdenken will überall
hässliche menschen egal wo man hinschaut
bist du im spiegel labyrinth der war gar
nicht mehr so beschissen wtf habt gerade
gekotzt weil du dich im spiegel
betrachten
neuerdings spiegel whatsapp hitze hier
schreibt jemand einer dame kaktus
daraufhin antwortet sie nein das heißt
kakteen und daraufhin er wiederum nehme
ich meine schuldig ja das war wieder
richtig witzig ihnen vorhin mit dem
postboten zusammengestoßen ups dhl
also
so lustig also absolute comedy
legastheniker wieder welche zeit form
ist ich bin schön bei dir vergangenheit
der war gar nicht mal so beschissen hier
schreibt jemand seinen kollegen sei mal
einen tag wie volvic er antwortet nur
fragezeichen weiß nicht was abgeht und
der andere schreibt dann wiederum still
der ist tatsächlich auch gar nicht so
schlecht da muss man auch merken schatz
wo steht mein essen im kochbuch auf
seite 12
lustig
sag mal was arsch [ __ ] es hühnchen
danke ich wollte meiner mutter zeigen
wie whatsapp funktion
kennt ihr diese momente wenn man seinen
eltern was zeigen wir auf dem handy
nehmen direkt das handy an sich dann hat
man auch immer angst hast dann irgendwie
eine bescheuerte nachricht schreib ich
bin fett erkältet du hast das und
vergessen
der ist bisher der beste finde ich bei
der nächsten störung schmeiße ich dich
aus dem fenster das wäre aber
körperverletzungen ein
umweltverschmutzung und jetzt auch gar
nicht mehr so scheiße du magst mich
nicht mehr wieso sollte ich dich nicht
mehr mögen ich möchte dich noch nie
das sind mittlerweile gar nicht mehr
whatsapp feld sondern eher dissel die
veranstaltet werden ist der typ auf
deinem profil bild dein freund das ist
meinem namen
wer allerdings jetzt auch meine damen
und herren zum letzten rottweil der user
hier heute vorbereitet hat und zwar
schreibt jemand seiner mutter mama sag
mal wolltest du damals eigentlich einen
jungen oder ein mädchen daraufhin
antwortet die mutter dann naja
eigentlich wollte ich nur einen film
gucken also das war ein eltern dies auf
einem ganz ganz ganz ganz hohem niveau
anderer stelle ich das heute wieder
sauber entweder lieben freunde werden
das gerne einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video der unterboden in die kommentare
welche nemo die ihr am meisten nutzt
schreibt mir außerdem gelten die
kommentare ob ich eventuell nochmal auf
solche whatsapp feld reagieren soll weil
irgendwie waren sie halt schon ein
bisschen lustig das waren halt nicht so
richtige fällt sie wie jetzt bei ebay
werden sie einer verschrieben hat oder
und so weiter und so fort sondern es war
eher so dass in jedem einzelnen whatsapp
chat verlauf der so rüber gebracht wurde
also wenn ihr da bock drauf hat dann
schreibst ja auch gerne und in die
kommentare falls sie noch kein teil der
lu crew seit könnt ihr auf abonnieren
drücken das würde mich sehr freuen und
wenn ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr
auch gerne auf die glocke klicken
denn dann bekommt ihr kostenlos
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen und dann könnt ihr einer
der ersten kommentare sein die das video
dann kommentieren
[Musik]
am 1